برنامج محادثات الذكاء الاصطناعي يواصل
طرح المزيد من المخاوف في الاوساط العلميه
والاكاديميه من خروج خوارزميات الانظمه
المتقدمه عن السيطره وتاثيرها على حياه
الناس مطالبات في كل انحاء العالم بوقف
تطوير هذه التقنيه الحديثه التي باتت تشكل
خطرا كبيرا على المجتمعات وتنذر بعواقب
وخيمه في حال اسيء استخدامها هذا التطبيق
قد يضر العالم هو ما اكده رئيس تشاد
خلال افادته امام الكونجرس الامريكي حيث
اشار الى ان التدخل الحكومي سيكون مهما
وحاسما للتخفيف من مخاطر انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي المتزايده بقوه وضمن
الاستراتيجيه التي من شانها وضع اطار
تنظيمي لهذا التطبيق على حد قوله تشكي
وكاله ديناميكيه او عالميه ترخص انظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي على ان تتمتع بسلطه سحب
هذا الترخيص وضمان الامتثال لمعايير
السلامه وسيكون دور هذه الوكاله التنظيميه
الجديده فرض ضمانات لتنظيم عمل نماذج
الذكاء الاصطناعي التي يمكنها التكرار
والتسلسل الذاتي
التقنيه التي حققت قفزات نوعيه ابرزها
تطوير شبكات عصبيه صناعيه تحاكي في طريقه
عملها اسلوب الدماغ البشري من خلال قدرتها
على تحليل البيانات واتخاذ القرارات طرحت
ايضا قضايا وتحديات اخلاقيه يجب مواجهتها
بعد ان توسعت لتشمل امكانيه تضليل الناس
ونشر الاكاذيب فضلا عن انتهاك حمايه حقوق
الطبع والنشر والغاء بعض الوظائف
فليونسكو تواصل تكثيف وتي ره جهودها
لاعداد وثيقه عالميه بشان اخلاقيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لحمايه وتعزيز حقوق الانسان وفق
قيم تخدم البشريه والانسانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات